just to clarify things and set the
record straight the fbi raid
is entirely related to the arizona
looting
situation that had happened and it is an
investigation
jake paul is speaking out following an
fbi search at his home in calabasas
california
last week there are rumors about it
having to do with
so many other things that have nothing
to do with me
or my character and the [ __ ] that people
are making up is absolutely absurd
in a since-deleted youtube video posted
wednesday
the internet personality weighed in on
the rumors he's heard about the incident
and thanked fans for their support but
with that being said when i become aware
of someone around me who is doing
malicious things
they are immediately cut out of my life
i don't put up with [ __ ]
i don't surround myself with bad people
and if someone does something bad they
will be removed from my life
jake added that amid the investigation
he's staying focused on his upcoming
projects
my goal right now is to continue to
focus on myself boxing
music thank you to all the fans who have
been sticking by my side through all
these crazy times
in a statement to e.t last wednesday a
spokesperson for the fbi confirmed they
executed a search warrant at a house in
calabasas
but added that information about the
search is sealed
the fbi raid is entirely related to the
arizona looting
situation that had happened and it is an
investigation
back in june the 23 year old youtube
star was charged with
unlawfully entering and remaining inside
the scottsdale fashion square mall in
arizona
after it closed
jake had participated in a protest over
the death of george floyd
and the abc affiliate in la reported at
the time
that law enforcement said he was present
after the protests were declared an
unlawful assembly
and the rioters were ordered to leave
the area by police
he was charged with two misdemeanors
criminal trespassing and
unlawful assembly then in a statement
last wednesday
the scottsdale police department
revealed that the misdemeanor charges
for jake
related to his involvement in the
protests were being dismissed without
prejudice
jake had previously issued a statement
in response to the backlash he received
when video surfaced of him
amid the looters at the mall jake took
to twitter to explain
denying that he engaged in any looting
or vandalism
quote we filmed everything we saw in an
effort to share our experience and bring
more attention to the anger felt in
every neighborhood we traveled through
we were strictly documenting not
engaging
and he didn't stop defending himself
there
jake added quote i do not condone
violence looting or breaking the law
however i understand the anger and
frustration that led to the destruction
we witnessed
jake also recently faced backlash for
throwing a big party at his mansion
amid a rising number of coronavirus
cases in california
videos of the party surfaced on social
media showing the packed bash with
no social distancing measures in place
and lots of attendees without masks
i think we just have fun
really is what it boils down to and
we're just like
dude we're just a bunch of kids here
in this house that i'm so lucky to even
have
and we just run around and do stupid and
film it and prank each other
and we're drinking and partying and
there's
hot girls and there's hot guys and
there's dogs and there's
lambos when it caught up with jake in
april he
opened up about his party boy ways do
you ever get
um tired of all the partying or no
not yet i i didn't party in high school
and i didn't get to go to college right
so
i have to like i'm going through that
like phase as a young adult now
but i don't think i've gotten tired of
it yet
but he also said he had a responsibility
to be a role model for his fans
i think you know i have a responsibility
to be a role model and there's
definitely stuff we don't put in the
videos
so yeah the worst stuff no yeah exactly
so there's there's definitely a line for
sure
i just think like and this is what i say
like if people are on the internet they
can access whatever they want right and
they're going to find it
eventually but i do have an influence
and a responsibility so i do
draw the line
you